- You said your mom, this
is actually adorable.
You said your mom ordered
a song from heaven.
- Oh god, yeah.
- Please explain.
- Oh man, so I have a song on
my record called "She'd Say."
And basically it's been 10
years since I lost my mom.
And I walked into my house
this year and my wife goes,
"Oh, I got you a phone call
with a medium today at 1 p.m."
And I was like, "Uh, okay."
I feel like I'm supposed to
pretend like I'm against that.
I'm like, kind of into that.
So--
- Yeah, oh I'm into all
of that stuff, yeah.
- So I make the call and
the guy immediately goes,
"Oh yeah, your mom's here.
"Cathy right?"
I'm like, "Sure."
- What?
- "Okay, keep going."
- He could have Googled.
And he goes, "She really wants you,
"she's like, very adamant.
"She need you to write a song
from her to your daughter
"about everything she would
say to her if she was there,
"because she can't be there to say it."
- [Kelly] Are you trying to make me cry?
- I know, it was rough.
So I'm like, "Oh my god,
that's such a good idea."
And I'm like, "That's a good idea."
And then I write the song.
And my mom loved
"Graceland" by Paul Simon.
- Yeah.
- So I get this phone call
where she orders the song.
Apparently.
I write the song.
And then I get in the
car and turn on the radio
and on the radio's like,
"Ladysmith Black Mambazo,"
which is the group that he
went to make "Graceland" with.
They're nine males from South Africa.
They're like, "They're gonna
be in Los Angeles on Friday."
And I was like, sitting
in the car like, "What?"
- What, yeah!
- The hell is going on!
So we chased them down and
they came into the studio
and they surrounded me and
they're singing in Zulu
"I miss my mom and that's
what she'd say," in Zulu.
And we like wrote this
song for my little girl.
And at the end you can
hear my little girl's voice
say like, "Grandma Cathy" on it.
- Oh no!
It's like you're just trying to kill me.
- And what's nuts is now that
insane experience for me,
a lot of people have heard it
in different parts of their lives
and been like "Oh, that's my grandma,"
or "That's my mother
that I lost," you know.
It's been wild.
- That is incredible.
'Cause at first were you very skeptic?
You were like, "Okay, you Googled my mom."
- I was a little bit skeptical,
but that idea is very her, so yeah.
- Wow!
What a power, and then--
- So I think if you've lost anyone,
I'm pretty sure they see everything.
- Yeah, so watch what you're doing!
- Honestly.
And then I also think that
they can just like order songs.
So, those are both things.
- Oh my gosh, I love you!
They're just like ordering
songs from heaven.